when paramount announced that they were
working on a movie version of Sega's
iconic Sonic the Hedgehog franchise fans
were cautiously optimistic but after the
trailer was released in early 2019 this
realistic Hedgehog like take on Sonic
went viral as fans took to social media
to roast the design here are all the
changes they made to the classic
character and the new trailer the most
noticeable difference between their
first and second take is Sonic's eyes
much like Sega's designed Sonic's eyes
are much bigger in the new version in
the old one his eyes were shrunken to
make them more anatomically similar to
an actual Hedgehog this is still
slightly different from Sega's version
of Sonic
which technically has just one big
eyeball with two separate pupils as you
can see here Paramount's a new design
fade Sonic's blue fur into his tan mouth
for a slightly more realistic depiction
his eyebrows are also much more defined
allowing him to show a wider range of
emotions the new versions facial
features are also more similar to Sega's
design with his cartoonish nose mouth
and teeth Paramount's first take gave
Sonic wide nostrils in a nose that
blended in with his snout this new one
sticks out more like Sega's design his
disturbing human-like teeth are now
hidden beneath his upper lip they made
his mouth more animated so it can shift
to decide instead of being anchored down
to the front
what really freaked fans out about
Paramount's first take was that they
gave him joints and muscles
knees elbows and calves the sonic we
know from cartoons and video games
doesn't have a defined bone structure
the new take swaps out Sonic's muscles
and joints for the more cartoon like
spaghetti arms and legs
his torso is also more defined and
separated from his limbs instead of
looking like a child and a Sonic the
Hedgehog onesie there's more of a
triangular shape to the torso with broad
shoulders that narrow towards his waist
Sonic's fur is now a more vibrant blue
and his belly went from white to tan to
match Sega's original design one thing
paramount didn't change was the color of
Sonic's arms in Sega's design his arms
are the same color as his mouth and
belly tan paramount made his arms blue
and their first take and they kept them
blue for their second in keeping with
their desire for a realistic sonic their
first take had a lot more noticeable fur
on him the new take still has fur but
his body seems smoother to reflect how
he looks in Sega's design and the spikes
on his head and back are much sharper as
a result and more closely resemble the
Sega version Paramount's new sonic isn't
just anatomically similar to Sega's
design it also features Sonic's white
gloves instead of just white fur much
bigger socks and a much more accurate
depiction of his iconic red shoes all
the while still managing to make them
look like a modern pair of sneakers
overall paramount presented us with a
design that looks much more like Sega's
cartoony version of Sonic while still
maintaining some of the realistic fur
and texture of their first take in so
far fans seem to be happy with the
changes are you happy with the new
version of Sonic let us know in the
comments below